doctors detected the first case of kovat
19 in South Africa earlier this month
over the past two weeks more than 150
people have been treated for the virus
as the government tries to contain the
outbreak many are worried
twenty-eight-year-old sipping water is
one of seven millions of Africans with
HIV he says with an already compromised
immune system his priority is to keep
safe it feels like it's another HIV
reload of a sort that we are actually
really evaluating something that has got
a lot of fear towards people living with
HIV because we are in that denial of
saying what if I get infected what's
going to happen what are the issues
that's what's the next steps millions
like tipo have no option but to use
often overcrowded public transport while
private taxi operators have promised to
disinfect and provide hand sanitizer
many have been slow to implement the new
guidelines public hospitals and clinics
are normally crowded with people waiting
for hours to see a doctor
they are concerns the corona virus could
easily spread when you come to our part
of the world our public health care
systems are broken our intensive care
units are full even before we get to
kovat 19 so again there's a real danger
and this is why I think we need
international support for Africa we need
a mobilization of resources pour water
and sanitation infrastructure in parts
of South Africa mean that many may not
be able to wash their hands as often as
they should
increasing the risk of contracting
covered 19 in upmarket suburbs like this
one homes and spaces are large streets
are wide it's easier for people to keep
apart but for millions of others the
reality is quite different thousands of
townships across South Africa are
overcrowded dozens of families share one
toilet streets are lined with rubbish
and people have little if any space to
themselves the government is using TV
radio and the internet to spread
awareness as
as possible and as promised quarantine
spaces for people who don't have their
own it's closed schools and banned
gatherings of more than 100 people
compared to Europe and Asia African
countries have fewer reported cases of
the virus but some experts worry that
fully equipped public health systems are
failing to spot the true total and warn
the continent should prepare for the
worst famine Amala al Jazeera
Johannesburg South Africa